Film Courage: What's the most important part
of the writing process for you?
Josh Healey, Writer/Producer/Comedian - The
North Pole Show: I don't know what the most
important part of the writing process is but
I know that the the thing that I've learned
over the last couple years that's been the
most helpful and the most for me why I transitioned
from more solo performance and solo writing
work to screenwriting and being part of a
writers’ room is for me writing is not an
individual process.
Actually I tried to do the thing where you
sit at the desk by yourself and write a book,
write the novel, write the…and that's just
not me, I couldn't do it.
And so for me I write my first drafts with
people or I get ideas talking with people.
Just “What do you think about this?”
And the writing happens usually before I'm
even writing.
The writing is in conversation.
The writing is trying stuff out, trying ideas…
questions.
I ask a lot of questions.
And then the actual writing for me is I'm
still pen and paper.
I don't start on Final Draft.
I don't start on the computer because the
Internet hurts me.
And it’s not even the Internet it’s just
the screen.
There is something about the pressure of the
screen and so it takes longer because I have
to freakin’ transcribe everything but I
get sooner to what I actually want.
So I always start pen and paper and it allows
me to get free and really what it does is
it removes the editor in my head while I’m
writing if I’m on the screen I’m editing
while I write.
If I’m just writing freehand I get a little
more…that’s usually where the good stuff
comes out…usually.
Film Courage: You do something called ‘Why
I Write.’
You stand up and do Open Mic Nights and different
things?
Josh: Yes, so as a writer I got my start doing
performance poetry and spoken word and then
I did a little bit of stand up and then I
moved into live storytelling for this show
on NPR called Snap Judgment.
So I did that for awhile and most of that
is autobiographical or semi-autobiographical
or supposedly autobiographical but at a certain
point I got to…you know I have stories.
I can tell you stories about my life and that’s
great and I love to do that but there are
other stories as a writer that I want to tell
other than my own freakin’ life!
And there is my whole community and my neighbors
and my neighbors and my friends and my family.
I want to do more than just me on a microphone.
Yvan Iturriaga and I knew each other just
from Oakland [California) and actually we
met playing soccer.
We didn’t start just working together we
were friends/homies playing in a socialist
soccer club in Oakland called Left-Wing Football
Club.
I don’t even remember how we got started…Oh…I
just wanted to make some videos.
It’s early 2010 or something.
Internet videos, blogs, vlogs, all of these
things.
I was like “I want to do something.
You are the filmmaker in our crew, let’s
do something.”
And I think some of those still exist on Youtube.
They are terrible, they are freakin’ awful.
I mean the cinematography is amazing but I
didn’t know what I was doing.
I didn’t know how to write for film but
it’s just experimenting.
It’s just trying stuff out and then little
from little going there to making larger videos,
having slightly larger budgets and then going
from there to making the web series [The North
Pole Show on YouTube].